tonight we honor hollywood's best and
widest sorry brightest
to stay peaceful these things are
music's the cuts that we believe do
summer in a tree we had an epiphany
now we write the wrongs in history
this song for a film that was based on
events that were fifty years ago but we
say that Selma is now because the
struggle for justice is right now we
know that the Voting Rights that Act
that they fought for fifty years ago is
being compromised right now and there
are more black men under correctional
control today than we're under slavery
in 1850 when people are marching with
our song we want to tell you we are with
you we see you we love you and March
honor god bless you